you kept it a secret  um yes was it so hard to be like hello  how are you I'm Lindsay Lohan and I'm  not married but I am yeah is that hard  it was the hardest was he proposed to me  on the set of following for Christmas oh  um not on the set but offset when we  were filming and I did not tell anyone  because I didn't want it to distract  from our work and stuff so I was like  holding and then I was engaged and I'm  getting engaged in the movie yeah and I  was like I can't do this anymore oh yeah  you have to like switch which one am I  am I your case or not yeah well did you  know right away I did I said it to him I  was like I think I'm gonna marry you one  day and I think he thought I was crazy  did you think you were crazy no I felt  it you did yeah